et pour en parler nous sommes avec
antoinette laurin vice présidente de
république and in france antoinette lors
un merci d'être avec nous sur rt france
alors comme on peut le voir sur votre
pull vous soutenez le candidat trump un
candidat qui l'assurent les informations
concernant sa situation fiscale sont
fausses
il a toujours refusé de dévoiler ses
déclarations fiscales
est ce que finalement c'est quand même
pas une épine dans le pied du président
américain en pleine campagne électorale
non c'est pas d'utiliser car en fait les
biais de départ qui aura lieu demain
soir ils ont sorti cette information qui
est complètement lié par son avis crack
qui s'appelle alencar qui quand même que
président entrant par payer des millions
des dizaines de millions d euros de
dollars aux impôts américains et ce qui
est normal c'est que président trempe il
ne dernière pas de saveur est un
président des états unis
en fait c'est qu'ils ont mouillé c'est
que la valette qui donne on s'irrite et
son salaire qui est nos moments à peu
près 400 mille dollars par an autorités
américains alors je pense que c'est une
campagne de diffamation de new york
times et la campagne détrempe a demandé
de te démontrer ces documents et le new
york a renié refusé de donner ses
documents et c'est vrai que ce n'est
plus une campagne de diffamation
président mais je suis convaincu que ses
supporteurs ne vont pas changer nous a
dit notre avis par rapport à l'or le
président donald trump on l'a entendu
lui parle de de fake news
que c'est alors comment peut-il le
prouver aujourd'hui très concrètement
même pourquoi ne le fait-il pas à la
veille de ce débat c'est parce qu'abidal
ils ont imprimé des t-shirts en disant
que c'était une manouvre des campagnes
de la côte est de 2 brides pour pour des
crudités président mais ce qui est
devant c'est que si c'est le meilleur
démarrage que les compagnes de débat dit
il on sait pas grand chose
les supporteurs des trombes je vous
assure pas changé d'avis par rapport de
cet accord de new york à qui ils ont
perdu totalement votre crédibilité par
rapport de 12 pages mode sécurisé
ils ont perdu doit crédibilité pour
aborder pas donné les sources d'eau et
dure histoire en fait le numéro 30
autrefois c'était une bonne piste de
milliards qui étaient bien réputé mais
depuis trois quatre cinq ans ils ont une
balance quand tu vas présidente ment pas
parce que lui il ne tombe pas d'un
joueur du système de des gauchistes ça
ça vient d'où alors finalement ce
montant c'est vrai qu'ils interpellent
ce montant de 750 euros d'impôts
fédéraux en 2016 qui auraient été payées
par le président c'est 750 euros
d'impôts effectivement saint-ernel c'est
assez peu pour un président américain
pour donner alors il sort d'où ce
chiffre mais complètement en fait il a
renouvelé lacoste en washington dc idées
à des crédits d'impôt comme ces gens
noirs des projets qui sont tout à fait
légaux légaux et
en fait il perd beaucoup de crédibilité
dans cette histoire parce que on sait
bien que président entrant qui
travaillent gratuitement depuis trois
ans et ne font aucune salaire même si ça
vaut 400 millions $ par an et donne
entièrement son salaire austérité
américain alors c'est normal qu'il ne
fait pas des impôts salaire qu'ils
touchent en dollars par an
symboliquement c'est cela qui va pouvoir
le prouver assez rapidement selon vous
où il faut qu'il le fasse pour les
devants les américains seront jamais en
fait en fait l'équipe légale des
présidents ils ont demandé quelles sont
vos sources
new york times et est-ce que vous pouvez
nous fournissez d'arguments et voulait
pas fournir ces documents
alors ce n'est pas possible de combattre
une accusation comme ça si il donné par
les sources
en plus c'est une un peu l'habitude des
côtés des démocrates
et oui oui il a fait la même chose en
2012 contre mi 3 min il a dit que vous
n'avez pas payé des impôts
il a mis sa seule d'un mécénat et
finalement il avait trompé ça c'est
dommage parce que c'est vrai que ça
c'est la seule accusation que l'été
n'est pas raison contre la présidente
qui a vraiment en vercors très propre
alors tout cas c'est dans ce contexte
demain qui aura lieu le premier débat
entre donald trump et joe biden à quoi
est-ce que l'on peut s'attendre selon
vous on y va détruire il aimerait sans
doute vous voulez dire qu'est ce que
vous supportez vous êtes une militante
on rappelle médiatique mais en fait by
dell il peut pas répondre à une question
il est vraiment en position depuis 47
ans il a vécu sur le dos des des impôts
sable américain
et puis de 47 ans et n'a rien dit depuis
que 27 ans et pourquoi les électeurs
électorat ben oui comme vont porter que
ça va changer avec byden c'est
totalement n'importe quoi
by dell il est sénile et les vraiment
pas en santé pour devenir président en
est vraiment on va voir ça démarre ce
soir ça fait rêver c'est immense c'est
votre avis est ce que dit aussi
régulièrement de donald fehr en tout cas
au niveau des sondages au 28 septembre
2020 49,8 % pour joe biden 42 9%
pour donald trump donc soit près de 7
points de plus pour jeune hayden est ce
que le gamin de 15 ans d'âge alors je
vous donne la source dans un instant que
je n'ai pas sur moi et en tout cas est
ce que le sondage pourrait donner la
donne et comment on avait dit en 2007
que les sondages ne compte pour pas
grand chose
hélas si on peut faire une petit rappel
en 1995 c'était la même situation entre
président vienne et modèles et freiner
le rythme il a tourné tout les pays acp
en républicain et je soupçonne que ça va
être d'accord
malgré les sondages malgré les les
les accusations totalement fausses
contre à défendre on va voir que la
plupart des américains
on peut dire les majorités aux mondiaux
on n'est pas pour casser une autre
histoire
on n'est pas pour faire les foules
boulet nos villes boulet le bon n'est
pas pour en fait on voit ce qui se passe
avec la gauche soutenue ou part
peut-être obama part peut-être par
george soros et nous on ne voit pas ce
qui s'est jamais eu de comportement
comme une solution pour améliorer
améliorée
pour payer alors mon public est
fortement possible que nous allons
gagner et le sénat et les prési
dentielle et moi je crois à 100% que la
plupart des américains vont voter contre
ce genre de comportement bio dont
accusations fausses
alors et je suis je reviens
effectivement sur le sondage alors c'est
un sondage rires politique et puis un
autre sondage du centre d'études si
dense à l'université de cân tho et se
tromper en 2006 aussi oui écrire par 538
et des arts à bruxelles
bon les sondages et peu et il faut le
prendre en contre et prendre un petit
parti dévot des électorats et il donne
temps effectivement ça donne un cap ça
n'a jamais effectivement donné les
résultats dans beaucoup d'écrits de l'ex
y ont d'ailleurs peut-être pour conclure
il ya eu des manifestations violentes
qui se sont multipliées ces derniers
mois aux etats-unis alors à ce qu'ils
profitent elles selon vous en vue des
élections venture sas et la stratégie de
la gauche mais je pense que ça va je ne
sais pas comment dire ans qu'on fait
mais ça va backfire ça va en fait les
devenir détruit mon allure partie parce
que de tous par des américains et quoi
dans les manifestations de paix on a là
doit tout à fait de manifester contre
note au gouvernement
mais dans notre façon de paix une façon
font boule et les villes sans brûler les
versements s'envoler les les entreprises
des autres américains et ceux qui disent
que black light bearer en fait et blues
legault entreprises à répondre des
coiffeuses de restaurants ils sont en
train de détruire leurs propres
supporteurs et ça va vraiment passé ma
peau et
merci en tout cas antoine est loin
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes vice présidente
de république m
in france